every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you imagine me every
little thing that's feeding your
greenido I bear that you beside me
without what's record a podcast awesome
well first let's say thanks to the folks
over here going to doing sign language I
got to run in the mouth side thank you
it's so awesome their role to provide
that service so we're really grateful
thank you so usually what we do when we
record a podcast as we take phone calls
but since you're here tonight let's
let's have a look at a level of the talk
so we set up a microphone over here and
Sean if you're ready to record can I get
some sort of signal somewhere
[Music]
that's the signal texture ladies and
gentlemen podcast John
he is the man behind the minimalism and
he keeps our podcast sound good we're
grateful for that so we'll go ahead and
get started hello everyone my name is
Joshua fields Melbourne I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to a live version of
the minimalist podcast we are here at
the Neptune theatre and beautiful
Seattle
[Applause]
ah
that is so great so we're doing what we
do three long-winded questions actually
long-winded answers
there'll be normal questions I'm sure
but our our answers will will be
monitoring and in some fashion
and then we'll move on to a lightning
round we've been doing the lightning
round a little bit differently we have a
rap battle on stage but without the
rapping but it's a bit of a contest
between this to see who can who can put
out the biggest maxims and we're going
to go ahead and start going to give us
your name and where you're from and what
your question is hi there my name is Uni
I'm from Issaquah Washington and I've
been one of your fans for about six
months okay
and I am one of those obnoxious
corporate America success folks I'm a
director of operations
just like you Josh my question for you
is after you have found a success that
you have found what has changed in your
experience as a minimalist because I
feel that I've adopted a lot of the
things that you and Ryan have described
and I found a lot of happiness my
husband right over there second row over
there he's very happy that I've adopted
your minimalist philosophy as you know
you just have a Chanel necklace here I
find a lot of value my Chanel necklace
I'm going to keep it but you know after
you found your success and your
happiness in the philosophy what has
changed for you in the maximum that you
have for your life after the next so
that that's the past year person sure so
I can tell you quite a while not even
quite a few things everything has
changed for me over the last seven years
there's no question about that but but
many things that have have changed
gradually as well I think the thing that
was most noticeable within the first
year - was I started to align my actions
with the person I wanted to be as a
those two the person I was supposed to
be this this image of whatever you might
call it the American Dream or corporate
success or or fill in the blank I mean
it really were often living up to
someone else's ideals and I know I
certainly was living towards someone
else's expectations letting other people
set the standards for my life and that
was quite a problem and now I get the
opportunity to have fewer expectations
in my life but high standards still and
so I've raised my standards with respect
to the most important areas of my life
my health I used to weigh 80 pounds more
than I weigh now my relationships are
better than they've ever been and and
I'm more creative in different ways than
I've ever been and those were areas I
forsook for the longest time and now I'm
able to focus on those things but a lot
of other things have changed in my life
as well you have a three year old now
and so my life is 35 looks drastically
different even from my minimalist life
at 28 or 29 and that's because as my
circumstances change as any of our
circumstances change it's appropriate to
ask what adds value to my life let go of
the things that don't also be willing to
bring new things into your life that
that do add value and so I'm constantly
asking that question I think that's the
thing about minimalism is we never get
there there isn't a destination I really
wish I could give you all a printout
list of 100 items you can own and then
be happy but I think happiness is the
problem I think happiness is something
we chase and chase and chase and then we
get these little tweeting bits of
pleasure when you take pleasure for
happiness but we all know instinctually
the pleasure is of happiness you know
you can eat a hot fudge sundae every
single day and you'll get pleasure out
of it in the moment it's not going to
make you very happy the next day or the
next day next day
fact the discontent is going to compound
day after day and so instead now a
little bit more meaningful life and
happiness tends to be a beautiful
byproduct of that so I'm when people ask
me are you happy these days my honest
answer to that is I'm happier I don't
walk around in a perpetually manic state
I don't think that would be healthy but
I am certainly happier but more
important than that I live a life of
purpose and I'm grateful for that um I
just want to clarify saying you know
we're not against like people who work
for corporations I mean I think well I
mean she started her question off like
I'm one of those annoying people that
worked at the corporation but you know
it if I think about this a lot like if
our books spontaneously combusted
you know the web's the internet blew up
and like I had to go find a normal 9 to
5 job I would have no problem if I found
the right corporation to work for it for
me when the work of the corporation I
was working for more importantly the
things that I was doing at that job it
just it did not align with my my
long-term values and beliefs and that is
where am I thinking you can get really
dangerous and I think that's like a
perfect recipe for discontent so I'm
just throwing the nathas I don't want
people to feel bad if they you know if
they got a regular nine-to-five I think
as long as you're doing something that
aligns with those long-term bodies and
beliefs that's that's the important part
and that's really how much or how my
life has changed so much over the last
several years I remember when that
packing party when that was over when
the party was over
and I was sitting there looking at you
know 80% of my boxes my are any kind of
80% of my stuff so sitting in those
boxes and I thought about like the
narrative that I was playing out and
when I was telling myself and you know
up to that point I always told myself
like well if you work really hard and
you save enough money you could probably
retire at a young age 45 50 and then I
could do what I actually wanted to do
once I would you know once I could get
to that that point of retirement but
until then I was going to work this 60
70 80 hour weeks but then like I sat
there and thought to myself wait a
minute here are tens of thousands of
dollars worth of things that I have put
in those long work weeks to buy like for
those things I didn't really have much
of a savings at that point so there was
like kind of the first the first alarm
bell that was going off as like wait a
minute I don't really have a savings
right now and if I didn't buy all the
stuff I could have tens of thousands of
dollars sitting in the bank account and
then I thought to myself what are the
other things I wanted to do when I
retired well I really loved to travel
more or I'd really love to spend time
more time with the people that I love
and again I thought to myself wait a
minute if I hadn't spent those long work
weeks forsaking some of the most
important relationships of my life if I
if I wasn't so focused on consuming I
could have actually spent more time with
my mom spent more time with my dad now
at the time my mom lived about a
half-hour away and I saw her 6 or 7
times a year and you know every time I'd
show off at a holiday get-together with
a family or a show for Mother's Day or
whatever they would always like assure
me how good I was doing in life like
yeah man you know Ryan he's living the
corporate dream he's our corporate
success you know good for him it's okay
we don't see all the time we know you're
busy
but you know it didn't feel okay and I
started to realize that what my
priorities were really weren't actually
my priorities because at that time if
you were to ask me hey Ryan what are
your priorities I would have said oh
well health that's a priority I'm not
healthy well then what do I have if I
don't have my health but what was I
doing I was I was drinking a lot I was
doing a lot of drugs I was leaving the
bar at 2:00 a.m. and in Ohio we got
White Castle like dead of White Castle
two o'clock in the morning it's not
deserve applause and you know I would
have said all my relationships those are
important but how was i spending my time
it certainly wasn't with the people I
loved or that meant a lot to me I mean I
was spending time with with people but
it was the wrong people you know I
wanted to set up a contribution like
that's really important you know you got
to get out there and give back I mean I
wasn't really giving anything so what I
realized was that you know my priorities
it's not what I give lip service to
that's what I actually do so what I've
been able to do over the last several
years is to make those priorities my
actual priorities and and I think to
Josh's point living in meaningful life
like that is the point of that is the
point of the exists existence for me
until to live a meaningful life that
means my short term actions are aligning
with my long term values and beliefs and
that is what I really am so grateful for
we did an interview earlier today for a
newspaper over and um it's over in Japan
but they sent someone out here to to
interview us and they're actually here
at the event tonight but he asked us you
know what happens if you know people
stop showing up at your events and you
know you can't do this anymore you can't
tour the world what are you going to do
are you still going to be a minimalist
and I'm like yes like absolutely hate it
like it's great that Josh and I can tell
our story we can share our message and
you know we can come out to Seattle and
hang out with
800 people that is that is so cool but
you know regardless of this or not like
I will always always make sure that my
short term actions align with my long
term values and beliefs now I'm not
perfect like anyone else in here but I
will tell you that since I have adopted
this philosophy I've been able to have a
lot more wins than losses for sure thank
you I mean I really appreciate your
comments because as a woman working in
tech and as someone who is in a
leadership position sometimes I feel
like I have to stay in what I'm doing
because there are a few minority women
like me in a technology leadership
position where I can make impact and so
that's where I feel like I bring my
values so thank you so much and I and I
feel like you've made a big impact in
our lives my husband and I so thank you
so much you say that so much thank you
for that Patti hi my name is Mari and
I'm here from Palm Desert California I'm
here with my mom and this is our
Mother's Day celebration coming
hi have you bothered nice happy early
Mother's Day thank you nothing better
than giving a gift of an experience so
that's what we're here I'm first and
foremost thank you for all the values
that you've added to my life and it's
affected my family and people that I
know and so it's just incredible here's
my question I want to know if you think
it's possible in a marriage to be with
somebody who has different core values
than you do okay let's talk about this I
need you to expand on a little bit my
short answer to use know you talked
about it I heard it on a project another
live event you actually answered a
similar question you said if you had
similar beliefs that sometimes as long
you might have similar beliefs but
different values all the way around
yeah yeah so the way I look at it is our
values and there are different types of
values so Ryan and I record a values
episode of the podcast a recurring it
encourage anyone to go back and listen
to it it's episode number 69 and if you
the thing about our values is I don't
think they change very much over all
over the long haul they might morph a
little bit and or I think for most of us
we don't know what our values are and
that's what really really get tripped up
so it's not about changing our values
it's about discovering what they
actually are I know for me when I spent
most of my 20s climbing the corporate
ladder I was going against my values but
that wasn't intentional necessarily it's
just because I didn't know I didn't know
what was valuable to me and so I let
someone else create the template for me
and so in our first book Ryan and I
wrote it's called minimalism love a
meaningful life we're
about the five core values or we're
really what we call foundational values
core value is a little bit different
health relationships passion or you
might call creativity growth and
contribution those are the initial
values that I uncovered for living a
more meaningful life I think once you
have that to select the foundation of a
house and then you build on top of that
your core values so core values might be
things like education and sexuality and
I mean I have a list of about 2025
values I talked about a little bit in
that podcast and I've been writing a bit
about it as well because I hope it makes
its way into a future book at some point
but I think that those values can be a
little bit different but they're going
to be pretty similar and you can have
different values on your list but if
they're radically different or they're
opposing values that's where we start to
get into trouble the last two sets of
values we have are our minor values
these are things that value our lives
occasionally they're not needs or
necessities but they're once and like
that we truly do get value from and then
there's the the fourth area the fourth
layer there these are the imaginary
values they're not real values at all
and we get so caught up in that and I
find for some of us like something might
be an imaginary value in my life could
actually be a minor value for you so
I'll give an example an imaginary value
from for me and my personal life is
social media I stopped using social
media about a month ago and at least on
my phone and so I still have social
media accounts and if I if I want to
post to them on when I get to a you know
a glowing screen and I can that can type
something out I will do that but I know
ever have the heaven on on on my person
all the time right I heard someone
recently refer to the the smartphone as
the 79th organ
and and it feels that way sometimes
right I was I was eating lunch at this
fine dining establishment today Chipotle
and while I was there I I noticed I was
in line and like I was the only person
not staring in my screen but I also know
that a month and a half ago I probably
would have been and I've been thinking
about it that much so it's not me
judging anyone it's just me becoming
more aware I think ultimately awareness
is the most precious kind of freedom and
so I think we need to identify what our
values are and then we also need to
surround ourselves with people who have
similar values the beliefs side is a bit
different give you a couple of examples
real quick so Ryan and I have very
similar values we have pretty different
beliefs we also have different
personalities as well he is an extrovert
I'm an introvert he is like really in
the moment all the time and I am like
the guy who wants to plan everything out
six months in advance and because we are
if you put us on myers-briggs scale like
we are polar opposites but we complement
each other in a way and so as a result
we tend to have different beliefs as
well because we have different
personality so one example is one of us
is religious one of us isn't and well we
voted for two different people in the
last election
how could you possibly be best friends
with someone who voted for someone else
Deborah from you well it's because we
have different we have different beliefs
and so we have the same values so the
beliefs are the path they get you to
those values you can take a different
path from someone and still get to the
same place you need to make sure you're
going the same place I could tell you
that the reason my marriage ended one of
the reasons at least is we didn't share
similar values and that's okay that
doesn't mean I was in the wrong or she
was in the wrong it was wrong for us and
I forsook that for so long that it
dragged out for an eight-year period
whereas if I would have been more aware
I could have caught that a lot earlier
we could address it address it a lot
earlier and so now with my partner we
constantly have difficult conversations
we talk about our values a lot we talk
about our beliefs and we talk about
whether or not we still want to be in
this relationship and that sounds harsh
at first but you we know that we're both
willing to walk away from the
relationship now and because of that it
makes it so much stronger because you
always know that other person is there
not other convenience or out of
proximity but because they really want
to be there
I wanted to say it's impossible I would
say it's impossible to be with someone
that has different core values there
between two people of different core
values but it certainly makes it
challenging right I mean you know when I
first met Mariah
we got along really really well then
like at some point you know she's like
you know I'm not a minimalist she's like
I really want to be a minimalist like I
felt like you know 60 pairs of shoes and
you know that for me it was there's like
actually 62 pairs of shoes yeah you know
for me like that wasn't a likin that
wasn't something for me to you know
break up the relationship because at the
end of the day like I really loved
Mariah I really loved who she was and I
was you know willing to continue that
relationship based upon the other
qualities that she had and now you know
I love her more than anything and she
doesn't have 60 pairs of shoes anymore
which by the way I've never told her
that she's had to get rid of anything um
that she will just kind of do some stuff
like sure challenge herself like the
first thing she did is she was like you
know I challenge myself to get rid of at
least like ten pairs of shoes and again
like I never suggested her to her to do
this and she hadn't getting rid of like
20 pairs or something but what I was
saying is as time has moved on a mariah
has gone out of her way to try to
support me because she loves me and
wants me to be happy and I do the same
thing with her um you know I don't know
how many pairs of shoes she has right
now like I don't count those I don't
keep track but as long as I can you know
walk in the bedroom and walk in the
closet and not tripping over stuff then
that that's okay with me it's a guys to
that point where I wish tripping over
stuff I would just have that hard
conversation about like hey you know I
don't care what he pairs of shoes you
have but I just want to be able to like
walk into the closet
that's never been a problem by the way
but I'm just saying you know to your
point of yeah you can absolutely be in a
relationship with someone where you have
different values when it comes down to
at that point is like how much do you
love that person and how how much are
you willing to give to make that
relationship work because at the end of
the day the people that we love and the
people that we want to be happy we will
support them no matter what it doesn't
mean that you know I approve of oh I'm
not trying to call any friends or family
out or anything but I mean there's the
things that they're involved with
they're like I just I don't really
approve of and it's now at the end of
the day like I'm not going to go out of
my way to spend a bunch of time with
those folks but I certainly will support
them whenever I can the chances that I
have to support them to to help them in
any way like I will absolutely do that
so you've got to decide or if you're
asking for a friend they've got to
decide you know how much do they want to
give towards that relationship I think
what when it comes down to with a
relationship where two different people
have extremely different values is that
they both have to be willing to give as
much as possible don't keep track of
who's giving more than whom but just
keep track if that person is trying to
get back because sometimes sometimes
people will just take and I think that
is where relationships can turn
pernicious and especially when a victim
becomes a victimizer like that's
probably the worst relationship to stay
in and it doesn't mean that that's you
know that that person is wrong or that
person is bad it just means that you
know that those two people are you know
necessarily compatible but I would say
at the end of the day if you are willing
to support each other and willing to
give as much as possible each of you
that relationship can absolutely work it
might make it a little bit more
difficult with the different values but
if it can totally still work choose
another person
just real quick one is if you're
thinking you're not compatible if
someone there's a good chance you're
probably not and I know that's a hard
thing to hear it's a hard thing for me
to say but I've learned from experience
at this point and then a second thing is
I'll just echo Orion said if every
relationship should be give and take I
should be getting something from
relation relationship I should be able
to give something from a relationship as
well otherwise and it doesn't mean it's
equal I'm not sure I shouldn't always
give what I expected yet sometimes I can
give way more to a friendship and
acquaintance a romantic relationship
than I can take sometimes I need more
from that than I can give at that time
and that's okay it's most people go into
that relationship with the understanding
and it gets great and last thing I'll
say is well I don't think our values
will necessarily change that much
they might shift a little bit our
beliefs can change radically over time
I'll give you one example from my own
life if you recurrently five years ago
and asked me if I was ever going to have
kids my answer was no hell no it is hard
it's hardest thing I've ever had to do
and and then I met Rebecca and she had a
one-year-old Ella and actually I was the
reason that we met was flirting with me
at the grocery store
and and so that's that's how we met and
and my initial belief was no there's no
way it's not the rat that's not the road
I want to go down and and I need to be
honest about that so that I don't I
don't like I don't like give birth to a
kid and then all of a sudden I'm not the
right parent for that but then I eat
into this relationship and I realized
wow like Rebecca is so outstanding like
in this relationship is so ideal that I
need to lean all the way in and not just
tolerate or accept the fact that we have
a kid together now but really respect
and appreciate that if I want to be able
to get the full joy from yell is awesome
she's on Twitter too at Ellis and rich
by the way thank you very much thank you
got it hi my name is Paula from Seattle
hey Paula
hi thanks for coming to Seattle thank
you and following you about the last
year and I thought I know you I have
your podcast in my ear Aldous
so I am an accidental minimalist and
unknowingly have been working through a
lot of these things in my life over the
last ten years and I'm really grateful
that you talk a lot about not just the
stuff but in every area of our lives
and I had a whole question crafted that
I was going to ask about my business I'm
an interior designer so I work with in
people's homes but as I was sitting here
I realized and you actually touched on
it a minute ago but I want to go deeper
with it I really needed to kind of get
real about what I still need to work on
and I am addicted to social media and
I've listened to one of your podcasts
and sometimes I've moved my facebook
over to another page on my phone so it's
not on the front page but I also need to
use social media for my business like
you guys writing and you know I need to
have presence out there
I've worked recovery in other areas of
my life and I'm beginning to wonder if I
need to do some steps on it so I also
find that I'm oversensitive over
stimulated and that is that just sucks
the life out of me too I'd love the
information I'm getting but I spend way
too much time on there so I'm going to
recommend a podcast because it's one
podcast episode it is Ezra Klein has a
podcast and it's with a friend of ours
in the names Cal Newport you've probably
heard me recommend one of his books
before he has a couple gray ones deep
work
is one of them and another book he has
called so good they can't ignore you and
well I would certainly recommend either
one of those books when it comes with
social media
he had a great interview with Ezra Klein
now Cal is a bit on the extreme side of
the spectrum he has a great TEDx talk
which I would also recommend it's called
quit social media and here's the thing I
don't necessarily agree with this visa
with his thesis and the reason I don't
is because I know that I actually do get
value from it but I asked a question is
that value worth the time that I'm
spending on it and about a month month
and a half ago the answer to that
question was was no and so I still found
myself switching for the phone
occasionally but I don't know if y'all
listened to that episode the Ryan I did
on media but I have this whole app on my
phone now called moment and it tracks
the the usage on my phone and I mean my
usage has gone down by about half at
this point on my phone because I'm no
longer incessantly checking I mean there
were times I'd open up the moment app
and it's like yesterday you spend 24
minutes on Twitter I didn't even
remember getting on Twitter at all and
then so the question is when the
question isn't should I get rid of
social media the question is how can I
better spend this time and if you're
saying no social media is the absolute
best use of my time and great and I have
a friend and Collin Wright who is very
talented alternate does a great job with
curating and social media and and using
as a broadcast mechanism but he is a
robot and he doesn't have any sort of
addictive personalities like I do or
addictive tendencies like I do and so I
realized that no I was getting some
value from it it wasn't commiserate with
the amount of time I was spending on it
so we had to make an intentional effort
yeah thankfully we we have Jessica
Williams who's around here somewhere
you'll see her afterward Effie oh there
she is right there
ladies and gentlemen Jess Williams
[Music]
so we we hired just a while ago to help
us out with our social media because we
want to help we're always asking that
question doesn't that value with the
stuff I had to do the same thing with
Twitter right I'm not going to send the
tweet and say here's a picture of my
pancakes this morning because hey I'll
take any one cares but I think it's it's
really narcissistic borderline
solipsistic to be like look at me look
at me look at me look at me but at the
same time I do want to send stuff out
that does add value to people's lives so
just as a great job curating articles
about intentional living or simplicity
or meditation or just curious questions
and and what we try to do with that is
realize that you know there's 1.9
billion people on Facebook they'll reach
2 billion people this year and and you
know what a lot of those people instead
of us just adding to that noise maybe we
can try to cut through the noise and
provide something meaningful for the
people who who show up there but me
personally you're not going to see me
hanging out on Facebook yeah I would
encourage you to just try to try some
experimenting out Lake during that media
episode of Josh and I deleted all the
social media off or off of our phones
and I haven't added the fact actually I
take the back I added Instagram back
when I was in Japan a couple weeks ago
and then when I got back to the states I
deleted it the reason why I wanted it in
Japan is because like I wanted to share
my experience I can't tell you how many
people were like take lots of pictures
and I'm like all right like I will will
totally share this experience we had a
meet-up in Tokyo like just kind of like
a spontaneous meet-up it was really cool
to like you know share that with
everyone to be like hey look like just
having a random meetup in Tokyo this is
great but what I'll tell you is it's
taught me a lot eh it's taught me how
much I was twitching for those apps and
B it's taught me to instill just some
different boundaries and different rules
in my life
so you know now I have to really
plan to look at social media to get on
my laptop and some are like Instagram
you can't really all I can do is like
stuff so I really don't get on Instagram
anymore it's just amazing how the
founder of Instagram called it visual
crack and I don't think he meant that
pejoratively but I sure as hell would
right like it was it was literally yes
as addictive as as as drugs and it was
proven this you know it you realize that
these app designers well they're not
inherently bad or evil we are facing
something for the first time in our
lives where you have a thousand
engineers behind your screen
figuratively right on that working on
one app and designing it to get you to
stay there longer to click more to open
it more frequently to engage to post so
that you can provide content for their
advertising platform so I mean I would
encourage you to do things like that
I'll tell you when I got rid of Facebook
on my phone that made me had to go to
the computer to check it and it stressed
me out
like I was I mean we were at the airport
in Pittsburgh and I'm like dude this is
like I have I know I have like 200
notifications I have to go through and
you know what I had one or two options
well I guess one of three options like I
could continue down that road of being
stressed out every day to check you know
1 to 200 notifications I could have put
the app back on my phone but I did the
third option I got i deactivated my
account now like the minimalist account
is still there that's the last ton of
value just helps out with that not as
stressful but if it's getting to a point
where it's a net negative and that's
where it was for me I just I deactivated
it and I'm still alive
now it's funny because I've had several
because I didn't like do the whole rant
on Facebook like oh I'm deleting my
account hey yo I just gave it the Irish
goodbye but it's funny because like my
friend Fred I have friends and families
that like I had a friend reach out to me
today and he's like dude did you block
me on Facebook or my sister did you
block me on Facebook of like no I just
deleted it like I would never you stole
my phone number like I wouldn't wouldn't
hide myself from you but so it kind of
freaks some people out but at the end of
the day like just I'm not saying to go
and delete all your accounts cuz I know
you said you use it for business and
like I don't want to delete the
minimalist Facebook account I think that
adds a ton of value but if there are
personal accounts that are stressing you
out I promise you you're gonna feel
better if you walk away from it then if
you try to just take it in you know
incremental doses but you could try that
that's what I was doing for a while like
I was just going to it once a day like I
would check Facebook whether it's in the
morning or night I would do it once per
day I would spend about a half hour
going through all the the notifications
and you know trying to interact and
comment and it worked okay it was nice
because every time I would get that you
know that's which to look at the phone I
would just feel like know you'll get to
look at it later but you could have
moment' that with your business even I
mean I know some things that you maybe
do it twice today whatever works for you
but I guess what I'm recommending to you
is either walk away from it or at least
set up some boundaries that are going to
make sense for how you need to use it
and the last thing I'll tell you is is
the pressure that you feel is almost
100% internal now some people might have
some unrealistic expectations
hey I messaged you on Facebook 45
minutes ago okay like I have I have a
face to a personal Facebook account I
can't tell you last time I actually used
it but I know I figured
last year how to go on there and check
messages and there were just thousands
and then I just said well what's my
option I can either ignore all of them
or I could try to go in and answer a few
of them but the truth is that's not the
platform that I find value and so a few
practical tips for you one is find the
platform that is most valuable to you as
your business or personally or both
right and it could be different you know
for us we get a lot of value broadcast
via Instagram and Facebook on social
media to broadcast as the minimalists
but personally I prefer Twitter to the
to the other ones really short little
bursts I also enjoy writing a lot more
and and that that platform forces
concision and it makes your writing
better because 140 characters and so I
found that that's what works well for me
that's why I gravitate toward what I
want to create something especially I'm
working on new writing ideas or new
outside ideas you'll see I used to eat
one or two or three times a week from my
own personal account at jfm and and it
just leaves these little lines that are
working their ways in the essays it's
almost a way for me to test out material
and that's a way to make it a net
positive in my life so maybe ask that
question how can I make this a net
positive and if there's something like
Instagram my personal account if I want
to post to it and I either have to I'll
do one of two things I'll borrow a
friend's phone and open their Instagram
app log in and then log out remove my
account it's a pain in the butt or I
will download Instagram to my phone post
the picture I want to post and then
delete the app for my phone immediately
and again it's a pain in the butt but I
make that intentional so that it's
easier for me to to let go of the thing
and I'm not constantly checking it
Thanks so first step I'm being
powerlessness
thank you all support you thank you
all right before I move on if you all
have a comment or tip for any anyone who
asked the questions so far today if
you're listening to this at home at a
later date you can give us a call for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or send a voice memo from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
and we will air our favorite comments
and tips on a future episode Ryan some
time isn't you know what time it is yeah
it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalist lightening round you know
social media we are on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram at the minimalist
where as where we usually answer these
lightning round questions and we used to
have a day to put together our minimal
Maxim's for this but now we just have a
few seconds and so you can ask your
normal question and what Ryan and I will
try to do is answer it but to still it
down to 140 characters at least
eventually it might take some rambling
before we get there though initially we
do whole via applause so whoever
remember wins tonight we all know you're
gonna win Josh he stacks the deck that's
why you know we usually have like a day
to prepare these pithy answers it's very
uh it's challenging to do it on the spot
but all right here we go go ahead got it
hi my name is Christina and from thank
you are British Columbia oh thanks for
making the drive down we'll be up there
really soon excited again and I in
December I took a challenge to get rid
of five hundred and twenty things in
eight weeks and after seeing a
documentary I decided to go for him now
it's been over 1200 items
yes I was really proud she chose mental
checklist to people and having things of
God muda except sometimes she gets
anxiety and she asked me are we still
going to keep this so hopefully she'll
how old is she she's six
okay yeah the question I have and
forgive me if the badge is obvious I
can't seem to figure out of my head as
I've been taking a lot of my digital
files and uploading them onto the hard
drive
I've been backing it up online as well I
don't know how eventually when I pass
away my family will get access to this
and how would they get the log in and
see all the stuff that I've been storing
of photos and whatnot and I I guess I
just don't want the pictures to die with
me and just be lost in this Internet
world so you have any practical
solutions on how to bypass those logins
and how I can communicate that
information to them yes I will
eventually try to distill this down to a
tweetable answer but I'll tell you what
I do first what I do is I have a
printout and a file cabinet it's right
next to my will with my passwords for my
social media accounts and you told
everyone where your past food's ready
yeah it's next to my will and the same
deposit address is nigh and so you want
it you want a secure place like like a
safety deposit box or a locked file
cabinet or someone you trust like this
guy and and what what I have is that
person or persons will have logins to
anything that I want them to have logins
is I've given the username in the
password which by the way I updates
those and every time I update it I have
to make sure that that they have access
to that but once you do that then then
you can feel secure in letting go so
here's my short like I'm trying to work
out this short answer here oh yeah so
I've gotta get 240 characters right so
there's nothing wrong with prepping as
long as it's psychological prepping
[Applause]
and what I mean by that is is we want to
we want to relieve the burden I'm not on
ourselves but on someone else so so if
you yeah I don't like to show Preppers
or anything like that I think it's all
absurd but if you're preparing for some
future that's inevitable we're all going
to die then let's go ahead and take care
of that now so that we're not scared to
death of death
that's my tweetable answer um yeah I
would encourage you to do the same thing
I have the same thing of you know my
Ryan I have a back-up plan in case yeah
a backup file I should say in case you
know something were to happen I'm like
alright this is where all my stuff is if
you absolutely need it um man I should
just keep traveling until I get 140
characters 140 character answer I think
I would say minimalism is about living
deliberately preparing for death is one
of the most deliberate things you can do
yeah thank you
one other thing for you is your tooth
valve minimal scomp slash death I know
it sounds like I made that up but I
didn't you can see I and I wrote down a
whole plan of how we prepare for when
we're going to go and like the documents
and everything that we you know a living
will and Trust and emergency contacts
all that stuff you can you can check it
out I think you'll get value from it
thank you thank you very much alright
let's let's do let's do three more and
then if we need a tiebreaker will do
fourth fourth more having hi Josh hi
Ryan
welcome to Seattle thank you in the city
are you cute my name is Stephanie wall
and I'm glad you guys made to slate
coffee roasters evidence on Instagram my
husband and I are faithful patrons
so I'm question for you but before I do
I ask a question of the audience if you
could cheer if you listened to the
podcast
[Applause]
so I know there's a little joke in the
podcast that every time Ryan and Josh
say add value you have to take a shot or
a drink no no you have to get rid of one
item that's what that's what we're
creating I wanted to do that tonight but
clearly I'm pregnant so I was like well
I don't want to like take a drink of
water because the theme of the night is
minimizing and I want to minimize my
trips to the bathroom so I just heard
about your patreon studio campaign and I
signed up for that so I thought why not
give $2 for every time you say add value
to towards that tonight so now she'll oh
wow and maybe thank you so much for the
support that's amazing you're welcome so
I wanted to imagine all you and
contribute so on so my question I will
give a background so I have some family
members I grew up with who like a lot of
stuff they kept a lot of stuff and you
know me growing up I actually helps them
my friends get rid of stuff and
reorganize and then I went to college
was actually a lot of stuff and about
six years ago I came across a blog
called zero waste home and so kind of
started to you know learn how to reduce
my waste and reduce my belongings and so
how do you guys about a year ago and
I've listened to podcasts read your
things and I'm curious since you've been
with a lot of audiences you've taken a
lot of callers what is the things that
you find that people are what stops
people the most in letting go whether
it's physical things or relationships
what's what's one or two things that
people struggle with what's that
obstacle um I think I mean the first two
things I was thinking of when he said
that was the fear of missing out I think
that's a big one I think the other one
is just in case like that is like Josh
said in the talk it's three of the most
dangerous words in the English language
I mean that is why I had seven junk
drawers
this is all for the the just in case
items deal to you'll answer something so
I mean whether it's sentimental items or
whether it is a just in case items I
mean people are often there I started
with sentimental items I don't recommend
it and you want to say hey get rid of
your most difficult things first and I
definitely recommend that but there
there are a million different
justifications we give ourselves to not
let go of something but I think there
are only two reasons why we don't let go
this is my tweedle answer there are two
reasons we don't let go fear and greed
and and if we can if we can think about
the things that we want to let go of but
refuse to for some reason we're afraid
we're we afraid of we're afraid to lose
someone else's love or admiration or
work because if I get rid of that shiny
car because really what you're getting
rid of is your shiny car payment and
then maybe I won't get to love from the
people that I'm trying to impress that's
not real love anyway and if you could
find a way out of that I said well
that's here is not rational or it's
greed right I need to have more more
more more MORE
I mean that is often thought of and many
cultures as a mental illness in our
culture it's called success and so what
I found is that I realized that my greed
doesn't just hurt other people it gets
in my way and once I realized that it
was easier for me to let go of the greed
and the fear I think
my 140-character response would be it
doesn't matter why we hold on to things
there is never a good enough reason to
hoard letting go will always feel better
than hoarding thank you thank you
I think we're tied up there I want a
piece so this is what we'll do only win
I don't know you I got arguments and
I'll give you your pride back oh that
would be awesome
been missing that for a while yeah so
what we'll do two more and I'll say I
goes from there I'm gone
hi there my name is Alec I'm from
Seattle I'm here with my wife wind I
listened to your podcast on accident as
I come to bed
thank you and she's and she's listened
to it and it's like falling asleep to it
and she's really in thanks again now
that I just wanted to so we have really
enthralling content okay so a few
minutes ago you said that you know you
talked about social media and how it's
driven by ads and you're basically you
know doing the will of these engineers
who aren't necessarily evil you know but
but it's it's kind of a big right I just
wanted to compliment you on the size
your balls to say that to a roomful of
software engineering but but
but so my question is I I really I
really appreciate what what you have
done in my life just because it's made
her a lot happier and I've started to
you know started to lean into it a bit
the problem is I have a project car that
I've been working on for 10 years and I
have probably 15,000 pounds of tools
that I use on a regular basis to work on
that car and I intend to do another car
when this one's done etc she supports me
having these things because they add
value to my life but on occasion we have
the why do you have so much [ __ ]
conversation and and you know we talked
about it it's just it's a good
conversation to have and at the end it's
like okay well everything's fine now but
how would you reconcile those I mean
that those things seem to be at odds
with one another yeah they do well I
think we can't reconcile it a few things
first off yeah it's your whether or not
there's engineers or it was a roomful of
advertisers you know I'm going to say
the same thing every time I got a email
- you not from from advertised comm
wanting to advertise on our podcast I'll
tell you this we turned down tens of
thousands of dollars every month because
we like three to six million downloads
of the podcast every month and and we
could have you know just a huge stock a
pile of cash if I was willing to
compromise my values to to such a degree
where I wasn't offending them but it's
breaking them and stepping on top of
them breaking and so when I get when I
get emails like that I just used to
respond with a ha ha ha
and and then a colon and then a link to
our very first episode that says this
episode of the minimal is brought to you
by nobody
because advertisements suck alright
let's get down to to your tension that
and the occasional tension in the
household not enough to disrupt the
relationship it sounds like but actually
that can be that could be misleading
because there are a lot of small things
that will add up to a long term
discontent and we don't realize it at
the time and so I think it's important
you're addressing it now the old Apple
film is you want to kill Godzilla what
he's a baby not when he's taking over
the city and and I think that it's good
with your dressing it now right
and so what I'll tell you and I'll get
down to a short three word answer I
think but ultimately it has to do with
with understanding and it has to in
order to understand another person you
have to move past tolerance and you have
to move into acceptance respect and
ultimately appreciation and I think to
braixen what you're telling me is your
wife except swear you should moved
beyond tolerating right now and you need
to help her find a way to not just
accept what you're doing what she's
doing and doing very well and Bravo to
her for that but what can you do to help
her respect it and I think one of the
things you could try is you said you
15,000 pounds of tools I don't know if
you mean like British pounds like
fifteen thousand dollars worth of tools
or or just you know seven tons of tools
but what I'll tell you is that sometimes
limit
breed creativity and I find this to be
true whenever I'm creating
I will intentionally put myself in a
situation not of long-term deprivation
without removes the things from my life
for a temporary period of time and bring
back in only the things that I need you
saw what Brian's packing party and you
realize oh wait a minute
80% of the stuff I'm not using at all I
think you might find the same thing with
your tools it might not be 80% but my
short answer to you is limitations breed
creativity oh thank you I think she can
mean that time to think
I don't know if this isn't nearly as
petty but I would say it takes big balls
to admit to yourself that buying another
tool isn't going to make you a better
mechanic hi Rob oh I think that's
actually 140 characters - yeah
thanks man alright let's see if I can
tie it up here all right real quick my
name is Jen I'm from Tacoma Washington
[Applause]
so my my simple question if I got on
Netflix totally got hook I'm starting to
be a minimalist my question is do you
guys have any ideas on being a
minimalist with three dogs without
getting rid of the dog once you stole my
answer oh no you know it's funny like
people will always say like oh you don't
have kids so I mean to me it'll say that
cuz I don't have any kids it's easy
three because you don't have kids and
Josh is telling me about how he was I
figure where you weren't postman
somewhere and someone came up to you and
they're like oh this is your this is
your three year old I was at the museum
like a dinosaur museum with Ella and
we're in Bozeman Montana and and I just
walk around with our on my shoulders and
stuff and this lady can zhuzh hey you're
one of those middles guys right yep and
and she's like well you're not still
minimalist now that you have a kid right
I'm like well yeah and she goes and I
could see her walking around she had
several kids with her at least three and
and she goes how can someone who has
kids be a minimalist as it it's harder
to be a minimalist with kids but it's so
much more important and I think you
could extrapolate that and transpose it
onto something else whether it's it's
having pets or it is being in a
relationship in general or it has to do
with having a full-time career or
whatever it may be it may be harder to
be a minimalist with any other confines
but often that's because it's more
important um then I keep talking no I
got your pad you have a cat I don't I
want to do it be cat well it's not my
cat it's Mariah's cat foot but he Foley
the other cat minimize no I mean I'm
just kidding limbs on a very nice farm
somewhere
no I did we started to go on the road
with with that the first book minimalism
live a meaningful life and we leave for
two weeks and I dropped and his name was
O'Malley I dropped him off of my mom's
place for her to watch and then I come
back after two weeks in like he was just
like rekt thank you it just looked at me
like what are you doing to me
so I would like try and find people to
house it and just like every time I left
it would get worse and worse like he's
his whole mood changed it was really
weird and I felt really really bad so I
actually did find him like a really
really awesome home like the gal who has
him now I was her and her husband and
they have a child but like she'll still
send me like videos and stuff like of
the cat so he really does have a really
nice home yeah so what you have a cat
now yeah we'd have a cat now and as much
as I pretend to not like him I'm really
lovable at and I'm more of a dog person
like he and that's why I like the
O'Malley because he was he was like a
dog like he come up and like when I came
home from work he'd be like patting on
me and like drooling on my leg it was it
was it was really cute alright um
rambled long enough I don't have
anything nearly as good as that but I
guess what I would say is it doesn't
matter how many kids or pets you have it
just makes your minimalism look a little
different from others I think I think we
tighten up on that one tiebreaker time
here comes our tiebreaker howdy hi I'm
Jess and we're just cattle wash where
you help me get some last-minute tickets
to this thank you awesome
um I'm curious about how the both of you
ended up in Montana
you did a sunset magazine
okay yeah um we talked to this one a
couple years ago okay
I'm curious how you both ended up in
Montana and also if you if you feel like
knit ease or difficulty a bunam analyst
is tied to geography whether you're in
an urban area or a more rural area I
mean I tend to think that people in more
rural areas closer than nature
maybe earth less involved in things but
I know also that they tend are more
square footage and sprawling acreage and
the contains of an urban area and maybe
down site that's a little bit I'm
curious what you found in one word any
different seriously I was we write and I
were driving from Vancouver BC down to
Dayton Ohio is a very last tour stop of
our very first tour of weather this is
our eighth for in seven years so seven
six years ago and we were we were
driving through Montana and I never been
to Montana and never thought about
Montana but it was Montana summer and I
just knew I was like oh man it takes
like ten hours to drive through this
huge state we woke up in Coeur d'Alene
Idaho some folks from Coeur d'Alene here
right now we woke up 1/4 lane and we
drove into Montana and it like got
progressively more beautiful and by the
time we got past Missoula which is where
we live now first of all my life I ever
did a triple take I looked over the side
of the road there was a waterfall like a
little small waterfall and six naked
college kids
skinny-dipping it looked like an
Abercrombie & Fitch head
or really like what they try to aspect
in an Abercrombie & Fitch ad and right
as I looked over with a slack Joel I'd
this is not a joke
there was a bald eagle that was flying
overhead true story I'm from Dayton Ohio
only time I've ever seen a bald eagle
was on a coin and and so I like to have
a riot over me and we the whole tour
we've been looking for the place to go
to write our next book so we rented a
cabin in the middle of nowhere about two
hours outside of Missoula it's like on
the side of a mountain and there was one
traffic light in 3,400 square miles and
it was Montana winter when we got there
and we woke up every morning to negative
twenty-eight degrees and the only thing
to do there is right and so we did that
we wrote a book called everything that
remains it's so much everything that
we've we've ever created and during that
time I found we found ourselves
gravitating more toward Missoula it was
two hours away and we'd make the
terrifying drive down i-90 and the
Montana went there to get there and so
we ended up moving there about four
years ago and and I'll tell you this you
asked the question about geography
doesn't make it harder or or easier and
I think the answer is yes to both of
those I think quite often it's easier to
be a minimalist in a place like Montana
because you're less bombarded with
inputs just whatever those inputs my
being here we see the hundreds of
thousands of discrete inputs every
single day and you're going to see fewer
in a place like Montana for sure or we
were just in Vermont recently there are
no billboards in the entire state it is
awesome it is so nice
it seems surreal at first you're like
what the hell is wrong with this place
and your eyes it's like they're less
visual clutter and how great is that
but it's much harder to be a minimalist
in Montana even in a place like this
alone which is the big city and 67,000
people there and because you don't have
access to much stuff so if I if I want
to go and buy a piece of furniture or if
at any time I want to go do something I
want to go to a concert I have to drive
to Seattle to go to a concert most of
the time which is a quick seven and a
half hour jaunt down the street and so
it's a lot harder from that perspective
because I don't have access to as many
experiences that I want to have
experience that I want that I have
access to and so I think we're shifting
from a culture of ownership to a culture
of access if you want to own more living
in a place like Montana might be ideal
for you if you want to have access to
more things then you'll want to have
access to a bigger city and so I don't
see myself staying in Montana long term
it's been a great experiment but I also
think that it's important to graduate
from a place before you want to divorce
it that's why short answer
it's funny I just hear so many people
just say going back to the forget her
name before she who had the three dogs
the people will have a lot of excuses as
to why they can't live a minimalist
lifestyle and I'm not saying that like
protection are not out proselytized
we're not trying to convert people to
minimalism but you know I look at
minimalism as a practical lifestyle and
I think anyone can really apply to their
lives we will have excuses well I've got
you know I've got three kids and I've
got three pets or I live in the middle
of nowhere or or you know easier for you
because you know you you were on both
sides of the spectrum so you know it's
easier for you to be a minimalist but I
guess what my treatable answer would be
is there isn't one damn good reason to
not live a deliberate life yeah look at
that it was a tie holy moly
all right job sorry I don't have a bunch
of time for any any other questions we
need to move on to our added value
segment we're doing this one a little
bit differently usually we'll recommend
you an album or an object or a movie or
something that we've gotten value from
recently but since we're here in Seattle
let's try to get a little Seattle
centric yeah man Ryan what's been adding
value to your life recently what are you
enjoying here in Seattle someone
mentioned late coffee earlier if you
ever been displayed coffee they are it's
one of my favorite coffee shops in the
country um they have was it God loves
the brief the next door I went in there
I thought every single slate coffee shop
did this deconstructed expresso which
hearing that doesn't really sound
appealing to me like you know it's
literally deconstructed espresso like
here's some espresso here's some milk
and then they kind of like do their own
like latte cortada
type drink but Josh introduced it to me
somewhere in Seattle it is it is like
one of the best drinks one of the best
coffee drinks I have ever had so I went
over there and I'm like give me the
deconstructed espresso please
and the brief it was like yeah we don't
do that here man I'm sorry like that
that's the other slate over on the other
side and I'm one everyn ballard yeah but
uh I was like all right so just look I
was like looking at the man he's like
but we have other special drinks here
that we don't do at the other stores so
I'm like sitting there looking at the
drink and I could I could just like feel
him feeling sorry for me and he's like
you know what man he's like it's not
busy and he's like I hadn't made that
drink and so long he's like I will he's
like I'll just go ahead and make you one
man so he totally hooked me up so you if
you go there at the right time and look
pitiful enough bubbly make you
deconstructed espresso next door but
yeah I would go out of your way to go
this way and if you are a fan of coffee
yes the deconstructed espresso in the
slate over and Valerie Jackson Bower
yeah it's it's out of this world so good
yeah this have really good coffee in
general um so every time I Drive out the
Seattle which is relatively frequently
probably once every three or four months
comes to your concert i I'm always
starving by the time I get to Bellevue
yes I guess a taraji Bowl as its
Musashi's am i right there yeah so
there's one like a mile from here and I
was gutted that I didn't have time to go
there
but it is it's the best sushi that I
mean and we've had a lot of sushi on the
road it's the best sushi that I've had
personally although I've never been the
Tokyo so yeah it's it's great so that
one always adds I to my life because I'm
always starving by the time I get there
all right well let's talk real quick
about right here right now we already
had someone mention the patreon account
thank you for mentioning that thank you
for contributing Ryan and I are in the
process of building a recording studio
and a film studio so we can make more
meaningful video creations that NEDC our
documentary awesome well you can take a
few folks that are here tonight Matt
Devo I think is helpful is it that is oh
he's up there Oh Matt dia Vella
ladies and gentlemen
it's if you loved our documentary it's
all because of Matt I mean it was all
his work he directed it added it he he
did all the grunt work if you hated a
documentary
you can blame Ryan yeah sorry about that
and we have another talented filmmaker
here tonight
his name's Conrad and he is right over
here man in the ones and twos we're out
here filming this and we don't really
know what we're going to do with all of
this yet that's how the documentary
started but what I can tell you is we
want to make a lot more meaningful video
creations whether it's video essays or
live streams or video podcast is
definitely something we're going to dive
into bringing guests on and doing
different interviews or Q&A sessions we
want to do a lot more with video work
and we could use your help because we
refuse to clutter our podcast with
advertisements where we're asking at
least 1% of our supporters so if you're
going to become part of the the 1% that
is the 1% that helps us out in the
studio you can just go to the minimus
comm and click on the donate button up
there you can support us on a per
episode basis through patreon patreon
the service it allows allows people who
listen to a podcast or view creations in
some way to support on a regular basis
she's going to give a buck or two an
episode that would help us out a lot by
the way a hundred percent of the money
goes to these of the studio or to a
podcast Sean you know he's a family has
to support we want to pay him full-time
and none of the money goes to to me Oh
Ryan in fact if there's any money left
over where we get a minimalist jets
[Laughter]
what we're not why so we can get one jet
but yeah nothing exceeds like excess now
we we've got no way to do to donate to
charity and find a way to contribute
speaking of if you find value in our
podcast if you want to leave us a review
well whether it's a five-star review or
any other star review
we obviously prefer five stars but you
can leave an honest review we also want
you to be honest this month which is May
2017 for every review we're donating ten
bucks in your name to the against
malaria foundation they do you all know
this that that half the people who have
ever died ever died from malaria so half
the people who've ever lived on earth
have died from malaria and we can change
that $3500 saves one life if it because
it's enough money to buy a mosquito net
they're insecticide-treated mosquito
nets to save to save one life and over
the course of a life is $3,500 and so
every time we get 350 reviews we'll have
enough money and we'll donate it in your
individual names as well so if you're
interested in helping out at the freeway
to contribute as well you can just leave
a review on iTunes and there are like
800 people here tonight so we could save
two lives if all of you who are willing
to leave a review so yeah if you want to
do that just hop on iTunes we must
review and we're really grateful for
that well we'll save some lives together
and by the way it helps get our message
out to more people as well so it's not
completely altruistic we're getting
those reviews get to our podcast into
more people's feeds and I got some more
notes here so I should probably walk
through these really quickly
Oh afterward I'm told I'm supposed to
tell you this apparel and some of you
bought some special VIP tickets which
got you really awesome seats up front so
thank you for that but you also have a
special line afterwards so we do a
meet-and-greet afterward so once it's
all over we'll come back out there in 20
minutes or so
and I guess it's a special line for the
VIP folks but don't worry you're all
VIPs and in my mind and so we if you
stay after we give out hugs they're free
and transferable you need six Dan for
happiness 12 a day for growth they say
so yeah we'll be out there with that
we'll have books if you can't afford a
book or you forgot to bring your wallet
don't worry we'll buy you a book so I
will happily give you a book it's on us
if you want one or you can just come for
a hug or a photo or whatever whatever
you like oh and some something to use
here what about The Neptunes hit her
holy moly what a great place yeah I've
we've been to a bunch of different
venues in this tour has been so much I
mean thankfully this is the first time
we are charged people to come to our
tours because it stops just got so big
that we like Ryan and I can't afford to
rent this theater and allow everyone to
come for free but we don't really make
any money from touring what what we do
is we pay the people that we work with
and then obviously rent out theaters
like this we're really grateful to be
able to have the opportunity to speak
and a really awesome place like this and
I think most important I want to thank
you for being here I know they're called
some money to get in here but it costs
more than that it cost your most
precious resources it costs your time
and it costs you your attention and it
could have been anywhere tonight you
decided to give us that time and
attention and we are really grateful if
you leave here with one message we hope
what's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works printer
buzzing yell thank you so much thank you
so much Adam thank you
[Applause]
hey yeah I'll just wanted to break in
real quick I hope you enjoyed that live
version of the minimalist podcast in
Seattle real quick where we're still on
the road it's called the lesson out or
we're in the middle of the first leg and
we just announced the additional dates
for the rest of the year so we are
coming to a city near you real soon
we'll be in San Diego Los Angeles San
Francisco Indianapolis Cincinnati
Columbus Cleveland that's the end of the
first leg there but then the second leg
starts later this year we're headed up
to Canada Toronto Ottawa Montreal
Vancouver Calgary Edmonton and then back
to the states in Philadelphia Manhattan
Brooklyn Salt Lake City Denver Phoenix
Austin Dallas Houston Nashville
Washington DC atlanta tampa detroit and
milwaukee so we're headed to 40 cities
this year hopefully it's your city and
it's not it should be a short drive away
if all this goes outstanding we'll hit
the road again next year and maybe even
do some international dates next year so
stay tuned for that
speaking of what's going on in the lives
of the minimalists right now we're doing
a few things we're trying to build a
podcast studio and film studio all
together we want to give you a vo
version of this podcast we also want to
create more meaningful audio and video
creation so some video sa some live
streams some mini documentaries
interviews special guest a whole bunch
of other stuff we want to experiment
with but we need your help because we we
refuse to clutter our podcast with
advertisements and that means we need to
rely on you to give us some support via
patreon so my question for you is would
you be willing to help us out we're
looking for a dollar or two per episode
you can contribute on a per episode
basis just go to the minimalists comm
and then click on the donate button
there at the top or the donate little
tab there and it will take you to a page
and you can either donate via PayPal or
patreon patreon is the most sustainable
way it allows us to build and create and
by the way none of that money goes to me
or Ryan it's going to be used
exclusively to build a podcast in film
studio
Podcast John our producer full-time a
living wage and so he can support his
family and then also it's a hire a
full-time filmmaker if we have any money
left over we will be giving that to
charity and speaking of charity and
giving if you don't have the money to
you can't afford to contribute through
our podcast it's totally fine we're
really looking forward to you
contributing in other ways so if you
want to help us spread this message you
can go to iTunes and you can leave a
five star review or you can leave a one
star review you leave whatever review
you want I don't want to coerce you into
to what you should or shouldn't do but
for every review that we get this month
May 2017 which is ending soon we're
going to donate $10 in your name to the
against malaria foundation now did you
know that that half the people who have
ever lived on earth have died from
malaria and so we have the opportunity
to give back a little bit to save a few
lives so ten bucks gets donated in your
name if you leave us a review and it
cost about thirty five hundred dollars
to save one life because what we're
trying to do is buy a bunch of
insecticide-treated mosquito nets and we
do that through the against malaria
foundation thirty five hundred dollars
saves one life so you buy enough nets
over the course of one's lifetime to
save at least one person from malaria
how awesome is that and you don't have
to contribute a penny we will contribute
that for you if you leave us a review on
iTunes this month we can do something
cool we can save some lives but also we
can spread this simple living message
it'll get in front of more people and
into more ears so if you're willing to
take sixty seconds we'd be grateful for
that until next time we'll see on the
road enjoy these these comments and tips
from our listeners
hi guys kami here for the last 15 years
I have been approximately 95% of the
time underwear free why you might ask
it has nothing to do with me being a
minimalist matter of fact while I'm
purging like crazy I'm still far from it
and on the journey to it
I may never reach it or maybe I will but
in the meantime I'm walking that walk
with no underwear all my buttons
why you ask because I just have the kind
of butt that underwear don't work well
with but I wanted to share with you that
while this may sound like a good idea
from a cost standpoint because female
panties they run yeah but I have to say
from a value standpoint it doesn't work
out in the end because when your pants
double is your underwear you really need
to wash them each time that you wear
them so any of you thinking that you may
minimize your underwear pause for a
minute
think it through you may not want to
you're welcome hi guys this is Mike from
Rochester I love the show I had another
thought that might add to your
discussion of debt in credit cards and
long term loan one way to think about it
is it's you're going to purchase an item
and it's going to go into either
revolving debt or alone it might be
helpful to picture the interest in the
cost I know a lot of times in the past
when I when I made purchases I would
think of it as face value is $100 item
and I'm paying $100 for it but if it's
22% interest and it's going into a
credit card that already has a large
balance on it it's going to turn that
interest for a long time so maybe it's a
helpful way for people to avoid going
into a debt or making a credit card
purchase and then I don't know if you
have any shortcuts or ways to think of
it where you could you know had a car
battery amount to to an item to kind of
picture what it's really going to cost
you in the long run say it's the $100
item or $1000 item or a $30,000 car and
then even further than that you know a
$200,000 house and I think people don't
realize the added cost of financing
those items such as a house if you put a
mortgage on a $200,000 house there's
going to be a lot of extra cost if you
put that into a mortgage or you know a
smaller item on a credit card
quite often Ryan my name is Tom I'm a
huge fan and regular listener of your
podcast and I'm actually calling from
London England
yes laughs London as we're talking fish
and chips cup of tea
bad food even worse weather Mary Poppins
bath London I want to just speak about
creative limitations and Joss tea
speechless I actually love the idea
creative limitations ever since I first
kind of got exposed to and they'll tell
you how actually happened is in my final
year university degree study and film
and profiling product is going to need a
whole year making our final film
fictional piece so you talking expand
reside and rig sound so many elements
are going into making a good film and
we've done a really good slick polished
job and there's actually lots of films
intended for the kind of prize of the
best film of the year I was actually
judged by Dan harder and those who don't
know Yin Harlan I was the executive
producer on a lot of Stanley Kubrick
films so we're talking the shining full
metal jacket and an AI amongst others
and and you know forget in the bag there
was this film that we made really sleek
really well polished for this is it was
awesome as if you have a condemned
incident him that good and then actually
picked I it was it argued if you'd
looked at the film it didn't look as
physically pleasing and and everyone was
almost a bit stunned you know why is
this big top executive producer from the
film world picked such a basic trail I
don't get why it was rational was and
afterwards everyone was was Sun just
listening to what I said and he said for
me this film may be basic but it conveys
narrative is a conclusive story it is
film and and in that moment that I knew
that that's just so true I mean some of
the best stories that we know being a
from books or films it's not necessarily
about how well made a or how well they
look is merit they convey and I love
that because you can apply that to
everywhere in life be it your job your
relationships or personal life and we
get so wrapped up in all the things that
we think are right in towards those and
really you just need to look at the main
message the main
if we want to achieve for boots those
areas
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing you bring that me
every little thing that's esteem your
greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you gotta grab oh I
bear thank you son without such a hey 40
[Music]